I wonder so have you ever felt pain and
those few moments before what we now
know his pain crawled its way out of the
dark abyss itself yuchi had just assumed
everything was sweet now samiki was safe
migami would be all right and you would
follow up after and then kill sakona
along with Yuji and release Gojo who
would in turn take care of kinjaku the
plan literally had no folds apart from
the fact that they don't own the playing
field they're standing on this is not
their domain like I thought everything
was already messed up enough for our
main crew and we didn't need anything
else to possibly hinder them and their
efforts to stop this culling game but I
literally couldn't have been further
from the truth it seems Gage akatami is
all about letting us the viewers fall
into a spot of Despair pretty similar to
how I would imagine Yuji is feeling
right now just before we do move forward
into the culmination of sakuna's plan
and the moment he changed zuzukizen
forever if you are new around here and
want to watch more stuff just like this
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and leave a like down below as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people plus
I've got some big news that I'd like to
share right at the very end of the video
by the way enough of that let's get into
the return of the Demon Lord back Atop
The Roof sadly samiki was then revealed
to be an imposter watching this thing in
front of him cackle Megami asks the
Imposter who they are Twitchy
hysterically gloats that she's
definitely his big sister so this person
inside of Mega me is actually called a
yaruzu a sorcerer from at least 1 000
years ago just like a few of the other
people here mikimi who obviously just
wants to know why is told as she
pretended to be his big sister to use
the three points for her own game she
hasn't had a good fight in at least a
thousand years and wants to choose her
battle along with this location claiming
that she wants to take on sakuna first
moth like wings began forming on her
back before she jumps off the building
and begins boosting away Yuji and Hannah
like instantly go to give Chase not
wanting her to escape however like
everyone plays just remember back
episode 7 right here and right now
already in a moment of Despair sukuna
uses that opportunity to appear on the
side of yuji's face and utter the words
in chain as per The Binding vowel shown
in chapter 11 or episode 7 you hear is
intently forced to hand over his body to
sukuna without any hesitation sakuna
immediately appears on the back of henna
taking her out for the complete ease
looking over at me and me whose brain
must be going through it right now so
Corner explains that he once made a
vowel of Yuji having explained that he
can't harm anyone to Mega me he knows
they're from here on out everything that
he does is just a complete gamble
sending some form of like channeling
curse energy to yuji's finger sukuna
then proceeds to freaking tear his
entire finger off screaming at this
moment and like pure joy he explained
that it was a gamble because he wasn't
even sure if Yuji included himself in
the veil when stipulating the condition
that zakuna must not hurt anyone Megami
Megami typical man like instantly pulls
out the arm movements to do maharaga but
I honestly can't blame him he doesn't
really have any other choice at the
moment so as he tries to summon maharaga
zakuna Datsun graving his face and
restricting the summoning seal before
shoving his finger down her boy's
unsuspecting throat with the cursed
energy pulsating through Mega me an
unconscious Yoji comes to not even
realizing what just happened as per the
vowel stipulations however standing
opposite his boy he hears sakuna say
that indeed he's something interesting
in the future didn't they raising his
head we see that no one other than the
king of curses himself has supposedly
fully reincarnated inside of Mega me for
shiguru's body going back probably for a
last time I would say enter the inner
world of sukonas we see him monologue
about the intricacies of his plan for
Mega me back during the day when he
confronted Mega me as Yuji for the first
time he sensed unmatched Potential from
him his coustic necks and his abilities
he knew that he could have forced Mega
me to eat his finger then and there that
day but it purposefully waited until he
had built up enough strength instead of
Yuji to initiate the vowel atop the
building miguna which is like sakuna
migami mix up I'm just gonna call him
that sometimes the absolute Beast
himself stands there leaving Yuji stun
asking for his friend to just talk to
him yet as we all probably expected was
just about to happen the demon Megami
asukuna comes in will they charge and
punches Yuji like and this wasn't any
ordinary level of punch as well meant to
separated the fabric around the area
that he has on Yuji like it made Yuji
freaking throw up while sending him
hurling through a multitude of different
skyscrapers eventually though Yuji ends
up finishing his destructive path on a
rooftop of another building completely
unconscious and covered in rubble
noticing some people approaching the
area sukuna states that in every damn
age and sex always come crawling out of
the woodwork placing his hands together
it informs the sign of megami's tin
Shadows technique more specifically the
hand signs for New Way instantly a
monolithic sized Norway is summoned out
of a nearby Skyscraper with everyone
reacting in pure shock and or the size
of no way it releases it's usually
pretty ineffective attack that simply
stuns people yet this time it rains
deadly lightning down on everyone from
the sky above having recovered from a
previous beating henna quickly makes
your appearance by shooting over showing
up behind the revived demon seeing her
so couldn't realizes that Hannah and the
angel co-exist and thus she can recover
very fast to say like in comparison to
him and Yuji in the past given that
Hannah is extremely in love with mega me
I would say probably from what I've read
so far she screams in hesitation not
wanting to hurt Mega me however Angel
insists that there is no other choice he
is the disgraced one and must be
eliminated right away thus as Hannah
cries to get mega me back Angel becomes
reciting the Incarnation to dispel evil
itself speaking to God now she tells him
to purify all remove his anguish
transgressions and guilt to guide him on
the correct path instantly Jacobs later
initiates fell in the sky with some form
of holy symbol before a mess of pure
light energy strikes down upon the
disgraced one himself with a mass of
light bearing down on maguna it begins
tearing at sakuna's soul in an attempt
to bring me back antenna is crying
screaming that Mega me belongs to her it
appears as if the technique has actually
managed to work dispelling sukuna's
Spirit from migami's body but remember
like honestly hit just how I said before
the incarnated sorcerers and people like
sukuna can mimic how their body used to
behave while Angel realizes that sukuna
is still in control and manipulating
henna with migami's voice not paying
attention though henna falls into making
me's arms saying that she's always sadly
though she's unable to continue her
sentence asokona fully reveals himself
before going to strike on an
unsuspecting henna calling her a foolish
human shakuna like an absolutely rabid
dog bites in tears at Hannah before
throwing her across the entirety of the
building causing her to smash into the
side of the protective railing Yuji down
below watching this in shock and not
even able to comprehend what just
happened Witnesses Hannah thud onto the
ground below with no indication that
she'll ever return looking down from the
top of the building himself zakuna is
astonished to see Yuji somehow alive
after the previous blow with rage
beginning to fill up inside of him and
after realizing that he's lost the one
thing keeping him together and giving
him meaning in life Goji breaks and a
complete flash usually jumps across the
building breaking the ground below him
and causing the entire skyscraper to
collapse he Graves to Cone his neck and
screams his name before landing a
ferocious punch on the king of cursor's
face forcing him to dub back across the
street regaining his footing sukuna
wonders just just how many world usually
so strong all of a sudden then in that
freaking moment Yuji takes him off guard
throwing a massive section of the
previously collapsing building into the
Demon's face sitting him shooting back
once again sprinting towards them
himself yuhi grabs a piece of rebar to
beat down onto Kona worth with him
dating him behind the king of curses
sukuna romai said he should have seen us
coming after all Yuji is from back then
and what do you mean by that sakuna
right there eh anyway having blocked
yuji's strike with the bars to kuna
counters by disarming and kicking him in
the face while noting that kinjaku sure
is Twisted asuji continues to approach
to Kona trying to attack him he screams
asking him why why is it that he just
can't live normally like everyone else
why can't he live a life without causing
everyone to suffer Yuji continues
approaching when all of a sudden takuna
uses his curse technique slash to cut
Yuji across the chest replying to his
previous statement sakuna rebutters him
asking him why so weak continuously
trying to cling to life he continues by
saying that this suffering is only
natural and they are meant to live life
with this misery for a moment there Yuki
forgot that there is no reasoning with
him as they are and always will be
curses do he dares to Kona to chew on
his misery and suffering instead while
beginning to March towards the Demon
Lord himself passing him off is just
utterly pathetic zukuna uses his Kus
technique to continuously cut Yuji over
and over and over and over again yet our
boy is just built different and with a
rage-filled heart he puts the pain aside
and stuns sakuna by not slowing his
Approach at all standing there and
actually confused now on like what is
going on Shekinah wonders how in the
world is so tough then out of freaking
nowhere and just like during Shibuya
once again proving that the body and
soul are won making me hold sakuna's
movement allowing his boy to follow up
and Pamela's face with a fat right Hawk
elsewhere and literally just boasting it
over on a blowfish Express automate
enkenjaku I sing traveling towards what
I assume to be the current bait down
back in the battle and having smacked
sakuna in the face maguna remarks that
fushiguro is indeed stopping his curse
energy output which is allowing him to
only use 10 of his maximum output hence
how Yuji has managed to survive they
blows so far sakuna notes that well it's
probably expected when the job's only
half done but still considers it enough
to easily take out Yuji standing there
maguna is completely taken by surprise
as he couldn't see to Maki actually
slowly moving towards the epicenter of a
fight wanting to know what in the world
korsakuna's body to switch into migamese
Maki asks to be brought up to date with
Yuji just completely better than Bros
telling her to just kill him as he's not
gonna die either way boosting in Maki
attempts to land a fat head kick in
collaboration with Yuji however megami's
body is functioning extremely well
obviously you know from what we've seen
so far and he's comfortably able to
counter his opponent still Mahi with her
immense speed is able to break through
his defenses and send him flying
smashing into some railing nearby taking
the opportunity juji then grabs the
other side of the railing beans in it
around sakuna before Mikey follows up in
combination and kicks him into a
building nearby seeing the unharmed
demon walks out though Maki wonders if
it's impossible to actually inflict
damage with his soul Liberation sword
because sakuna will use his reverse
curse techniques to heal himself knowing
that no matter what happens here they'll
have to kill sakuna Maki charges insane
he'll have to keep up with his speed
probably running its speeds faster than
sound right now sukuna is surprisingly
able to keep up with the attacks of Maki
and Yuji but knows that whenever he
tries to attack them with curse energy
they pull from Mega me inside him is
stronger and thus to get around megame
sakona like the absolute big brain man
he is you his curse technique cleave
spider threads on the ground below to
utterly destroy the ground and
disbelance Yuji and Marquee with the
ground around them now falling to bet
zakuna is able to easily Dart in unless
he fat right Hawk yet Maki simply spits
out a tooth or two leaving him
completely impressed with how she's
hardly even worried with taking damage
asakuna falls back a little a mysterious
Foe and randomly appears from the side
and uses a maximum output technique
called Dead Calm the resulting aftermath
from the attack not only freezes the
entirety of the area but also Marky and
Yuji so their mysterious person happen
to be no one other than the coldest
woman out sukuna's right hand woman
urume who apologizes for a grand
entrance while saying that she's still
awakened the ice around Yuji just in
case they need him sukuna though
literally doesn't care for him anymore
and instead just compliment to her
stating that focusing her energy on Maki
was a good idea believing that
everything here is sweet now sukuna then
summons no way saying that this body is
still not so they need to prepare for
the bath immediately in that moment
though our goat though looking more
Bader than Bros than ever after this
Escalade burst his way out of the ice
noticing this or maybe proposes taking
him out but shakuna says that they
should just look at him and have a good
laugh flying away for what seems like
good in yuji's eyes sakuna having taken
the body of yuji's best friend into
uramae laugh at his face noticing that
he looks just like the person from The
harima Province
so yes I guess that brings us up to date
until the very end of sukuna and that
one time he utterly changed due to
Kaizen Forever on a different note
though I've actually started another
channel in which I'll be taking all of
the fights and most hype moments from
throughout all of these series that I've
already covered and re-releasing them
independently on my Clips channel so
this will probably be one of the last
fight videos that are like I guess a
re-upload in some kind of way because
this weekend I'll be releasing the full
Arc that has this video on it as well
unless I've obviously decided to cover a
battle like I've done with one punch man
and one piece in the past so go
subscribe over there to my dear Volo
clubs channel and once all the art I'm
getting made is sorted then I'll start
releasing a bunch of fights and in most
hype moments throughout manga that I've
covered so far for anyone else who was
confused as to why I'm actually doing
this I just want to keep my main channel
for longer format content and having a
Clips channel will hopefully allow me to
like focus on making longer format
content without freaking out over
actually not having uploaded for two
weeks because these videos do take a lot
to actually get out also if anyone is
interested and wants to edit chapter
reviews for me then like hit me up over
on Twitter or just like message me on
Discord or something as I'm looking to
revive the Volo Channel and do future
chapter reviews weekly but just because
you know like I edit script and do
everything already for my devolo channel
I need someone who can actually do that
over on the Volo Channel either way I
hope you all enjoyed the video and what
I've got to come in the future thanks to
all of my dope patreons who keep me fed
every month and obviously remember to
subscribe if you are new around here and
haven't already but for now it's been
your professional degenerate diavolo and
I'll see you all in a bit bye